i we discussed the question of security  and defense and also quite clear the  situation about the ongoing negotiation  between the European Union euro members  and Greece and we are hopefully that  optimistic until the last second that  there will be a conclusion we launched  also today the plan which is now after  signing on the road and I can only  express on behalf of the Parliament but  I think in the interest of our citizens  that the investment fund and the  so-called yoga plan will attract as much  as possible investors to the European  Union especially for something to  countries like Greece because we need  investment  thus Defrag a Democrat shown on belong  like the Commission but in fulfilling in  Divya with a bright sound for Anakin  rotten is how to dish and a half cab  reached their element and solidarity  toss with us which this problem in  Arabic demands of onion nutrition  Italian and multisim the Gonzalez  Viva Las Virgenes de Indias